welcome to this video playing card start
with black feeder master from Estonia
you re Krupinski let's see playing b6
English Defence a three very much afraid
of Bishop before happening okay so um
what am I going to do here c5 certainly
a move but maybe I can do something else
d 594 now why not Queen f3f 95 there is
no tactic or anything takes Bishop takes
I mean this is taking some liberties but
a 3 is not exactly a big develop
developing muth and things like if I've
very often are not much to the taste of
the of the white players playing the
English the English opening they very
often favored more conservative
positions not with this kind of non
symmetric of bone structure see 596 what
I'm trying to do is make this pawn on e5
a weakness if possible okay so i can
take i mean i can take a sign I must
take and what about this hmm giving up
the exchange here's a bit much can play
but I can play Quincy
seven here Quincy seven Queenie 294 it's
very nice oh it's just giving up he's
just giving me the pawn ok I don't I
don't mind the position is is fairly am
fairly closed so I don't really think
there should be lots of compensation
before hmm intending be five but I have
94 so I just need to get the rook out of
this pin ok so should I check with the
bishop or debatable I guess with the
bishop yam to get to get this developed
we should be too i have night d for now
ok let that's fine I want to I don't
want him to play d3 d4 so I plus I must
play 94 ok just take on f3 on move it
again I don't know I can play e5 maybe
you 5v5 maybe in Queen you one so move
like that 521 I can take f6 look sleek
look so weird so let's do that try to
make sure that this is please staying on
deform
maybe still Queenie one I wasn't I
wasn't really sure about the move oh
it's going is going Bishop d I see
Bishop he wants to go Bishop g5 and and
then attacking and very valid idea how
do I play that maybe we go back here
possibly night f4 attacking this bishop
or Bishop deform don't mind him very
much if he takes on age seven it's
probably not not very threatening now I
have a really good knight on d4
hmm oh just g6g 6 + f5 poor Jeff got
some pressure here eieio is active I'm
not sure where to put my king maybe
maybe on g7 after all I should
definitely get it out of the e-file it's
got weird pieces though I'm not not sure
about that this is so great
+ f5 coming and only need to be current
cautious about your checks deform yeah
nevertheless or wait wait wait wait
Quincy five I can also just do this
as Bishop is Vidya really a nuisance hmm
how do I get rid of this this pressure
here um Wrigley seven maybe I know
Queenie seven is useless but I can and
play this maybe rookie seven rookie
seven rookie ate something like that
yeah this looks like a good idea getting
stuff traded book chicks maybe just
maybe just pawn takes 96 is now an
additional possibility
f 696
or 2d 45 morning don't know
Queen have sixes what I want you to do I
get get this coordinated ok
at least I can play some quick moves now
like g4 and stuff going all the way to
g3 to have a say his King unboxed in
maybe it's really eyes got the check yet
what are the check unbelievable how did
I overlooked that two check check check
check check what is happening here check
check I know check come on is this chick
me late for fits on time uh what what
the heck was happening here oh man I
hope you're totally overlooked this is
Queen Queen g4 business check check yeah
I have no idea what's going on in my
last year I maybe I was just trying to
make moves with with no time I thought I
would lose on time I was always down on
time here here why this winning and
check chera what what crazy stuff of
course around here black should simply
win it but I played played without a-rod
very concrete plan I shouldn't have
advanced the points any further I should
try to invade on the queenside gem
definitely Queen d6 maybe five those
kind of things trying to as men should
invade on the queenside I'm not having a
was just pushing stuff here without any
big idea may be here be five yeah I
don't know how it was still ok up to
this point but he I must play at three
this is this is quite strong actually
the idea is that if this is happening he
cannot take because i have a crank made
and she takes this is obviously quite
nice with the pawn yeah i was just a
total and 20 times candle check it was
always hoping for a cranky tricks here
but check like like if he takes here i
came that it's a total mess everything
thought I would lose on time but in fact
I had more time I could really couldn't
really look I was just making moves ok
well thanks for watching